-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
John Early and Aidy Bryant.
And we were talking backstage.
You said you guys were
very close in real life,
and maybe we could have you
out here together.
So we made it work and --
-Yeah, it feels amazing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Just being out here together
feels amazing?
-Being out --
-Yeah.
-Being out here together for
once, not having to hide it.
-Yeah.
No, it's true,
because a lot of people
get talking,
and they don't know
what's going on with us.
-Exactly, and here's my thing.
Ignore the press, you guys.
-Yeah.
-Ignore the press.
That's all lies.
Like, what we have --
-Here's what we want to say --
we're dating.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I was just...
I feel like, again...
-I'm crazy about you.
-Ugh, that's so crazy
that you said that,
'cause I'm crazy about you.
-Yeah.
-Do you like this?
-I was just bumping right up
against things
you've talked about
in your individual segments.
Like, you talked about driving
cross-country with your husband.
-No, get comfortable,
get comfortable.
-Thank you, baby.
-Yeah, yeah. Oh, my God.
What can I do to help maximize
your comfort?
-This is the thing, is that,
yes, I'm married or whatever.
-[ Spits ]
[ Laughter ]
-But that's
the thing that's hot.
-Right.
-They fight over me.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Seth.
-Yup?
-You want to watch sometime?
[ Cheers and laughter ]
-I'm about halfway there.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm cresting.
-C-Cresting?
Do you want...
[ Laughter ]
-Seth --
-So, you guys, um --
Well, let me ask
about some of the rumors.
-Yeah, please.
-Yeah.
-Is it true that you -- I know
you recently released a single.
-Uh-oh.
-[ Laughs ]
-Why not?
[ Laughter ]
-Zoom in?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You dropped a new --
You dropped a new single,
and a lot of people...
-Yeah.
-...they think that this is
a song about you and Aidy.
Could you confirm now
that the new song is...
-Uh, I won't confirm or deny.
but at the same time, I will
very much confirm, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This song --
-It is about my --
-The song is called
"[Bleep] It, Suck It,
Might We Gonna Buck It."
[ Laughter ]
And it's about me.
-It's so beautiful.
it's a way more beautiful song
than the title
leads one to believe.
-Yeah, yeah, it's gorgeous.
-No, it's so good.
-Y'all should play it.
[ Laughter ]
-Baby, they wish
they could play it like you.
Y'all wish you could play it
like he could.
8G Band, get real.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna ask you not to be
aggressive with the band.
-[Bleep] you, [Bleep].
-I gave you this time!
I gave -- What are you doing?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause I am really...
What are you --
Who are you angry with?
-I'm really pissed off
in general!
-Babe, don't! Don't!
Don't do this!
Not in front of my friends!
[ Laughter ]
I'm going crazy, Seth.
-It's okay.
-[Crying] I feel sick.
-[ Laughs ]
-Will someone
get her something?!
-What do you want?!
-I need, like,
a cake or something!
-We can't get you a cake.
-I bet you could.
-Do you want a water? What?
-You're one of the richest guys.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what we love about you.
-Alright, enough.
Alright, you guys make up.
[ Laughter ]
That's John Early
and Aidy Bryant.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're a big-time couple.
-Get involved.
-We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
[ Cheers and applause ]